We've been passing an argument values directly into our function calls.
Like for weather interpreter function,
whose definition is here.
We've passed in different integer arguments for the temperature,
like four and 32.
And for these function calls we'll see this print output.
Brr, consider wearing a jacket for an argument of four degrees Celsius.
And, it's hot outside for 32 degrees.
But instead of directly passing in these values,
we can also pass in variables as arguments,
as long as they're the right type.
So for our weather example,
that would look something like this.
Our weatherInterpreter still expects an integer as an argument.
But instead of typing in a value directly, like 32,
we're passing in the int variable degreesC,
that's been declared and initialized here.
And this variable holds the value 32.
So this function call will print out,
it's hot outside, just like before.
And if we change the value of degreesC to say,
15 and use the same weatherInterpreter call,
this will prompt the code in our function definition to run.
And we'll go through our if test,
this time with temperature equal to 15.
For a temperature value of 15,
we don't pass our first hot test because 15 is not greater than 30.
We also don't pass our second test because 15 is not less than five.
We end up in our else block of code and print out,
not too hot, not too cold.
This way we haven't changed our function call at all.
We're still saying whetherInterpreter with degreesC passed in.
We've just changed the value of our variable to be 15.
And it's often a lot easier to change variables rather than changed whole function calls.
So passing in variables as arguments is really useful.
And as long as we're passing in an int value directly or as a variable,
which is the type of input our weatherInterpreter expects, our code will run.
And this goes for any function that expects input.
As long as we're passing in the type of variable our function expects,
as a variable like degreesC or as a direct value like 32,
our function call will work.